pendant la nuit parce que pour l'instant
on est juste une petite lumière dans la
nuit ça redonnera un peu de bonheur à
notre peuple et c'est tout ce qu'on peut
souhaiter quand même alors une dernière
question de françois asselineau
revendique des militants de gauche
d'extrême gauche de droite d'extrême
droite
est-ce que vous ça ne vous dérange pas
d'être alliés
de circonstance avec des personnes de
gauche non mais moi je me suis jamais
senti de droite de l'extrême droite
et chez nous il ya aussi beaucoup sur
qui viennent de la gauche donc vous
savez tout ça moi je suis gaulliste
à la base j'ai toujours considéré que le
clivage gauche droite y étaient morts
depuis longtemps donc j'ai toujours
tendu la main aux gens qui venaient de
la gauche et la droite vous avez quand
j'étais au front national j'étais le
gauchiste de services donc tout ça me
pose aucun problème au contraire